الاداره الامريكيه تعمل على تدمير اخر
الاسلحه والمعدات والقنابل من ترسانتها
الكيميائيه في مستودعات ابي علي الجيش
الامريكي في ولايه كولورادو صحيفه نيويورك
بوست الامريكيه قالت انه سيتم الانتهاء من
القضاء على المخزون المتبقي من الذخائر
الكيميائيه قبل الثامن من هذا الشهر
نيويورك بوست كشفت ان المخزون الامريكيه
تضمن قنابل عنقوديه الى جانب خزانات مليئه
بالسموم واسلحه كيميائيه متنوعه لكن لماذا
تدمر امريكا اسلحتها الكيميائيه للاجابه
على هذا السؤال يجب ان نعود بالزمن الى
عام
1997 حيث كان الاعلان عن اتفاقيه حظر
الاسلحه الكيميائيه وتصنيعها وتضمير ما
يوجد منها 165 دوله وقعت على هذه
الاتفاقيه من بينها روسيا وامريكا روسيا
كانت انتهت من تنفيذ بنود الاتفاقيه في 27
من سبتمبر عام 2017 لكن امريكا تاخرت في
تنفيذ بنود الاتفاقيه كامله حتى عام 2023
حين اعلن بايدن قرب تدمير ما تبقى من
مخزون الاسلحه الكيميائيه